you and Richie you're sort of like
getting to know each other moment so
Richie merit straight out Vince was
office in Baltimore Maryland high school
never acted before
gets flown to LA I'm sure for the first
time and one of the things gonna do is
he's gonna you're gonna you're gonna go
meet Matthew McConaughey's and we played
your dad he's like okay so I've seen a
picture of him that young man would walk
right past me going into the into the
bowling alley because he didn't
recognize me I recognized him okay hey
man it's Matthew
hey how you doing what's up we go in we
ball he flirts with the girl that works
there de Serre and a purple button-down
vest we're drinking coca-cola eatin
popcorn bullet we hang out for a couple
hours
laughs share to share some tunes things
like that then we go to a workshop and
then in pre-production we did thing took
a road trip together with his mom things
you know honey family means a lot to
this young man that was apparent to me
very early how important his own family
was to him and he came from a bit of a
broken families mother left when him
when he was early some things that are
some themes that the character under
goes through in the story um any new the
streets but family meant a lot to him so
that was my hook with him as an actor
that's what I was tied to get to Richie
Merritt every day when we went to work
not the actor playing reporter jr. I had
to get to Richie Merritt right there
let's see if family is what seals the
film yeah you know like when the filming
of movies like sort of a guy coming to
come to a point in the end you realize
that with everything that's going on
with the FBI and with the drug dealings
and everything it is all about family
but who want the Boeing match by the way
I did you did you're like I did but
there was no
I took no mercy this was not like I let
him get close maybe let him win one no
but it got like this he's uh you know I
mean it's not just like he's in a couple
of scenes in this his first movie he's
it's just move he's yes he is white boar
he is the fool along lead this is not
somebody who's done a couple of small
roles really impress people and now gets
his big shot this is welcome you're the
lead we're following you through this is
your story and he's got it obviously
he's got it because he has to carry this
film and he does yeah big testament to
this man here I told you what I did
working with him but Rihanna put him
through through boot camp you know I
mean to get ready for this I mean I was
like you eat what to eat I changed his
diet severe ADT they don't even take
pills for it we we just changed his
whole lifestyle and I'm an acting coach
you know I was doing sessions with him
okay I'm working out and I just attacked
his whole okay I did a whole 360 on his
lifestyle it was amazing remember the
difference you saw realistic sorry we
got four kind of step in in this guy
12-hour days five six days a week it's
an endurance test for those of us who've
done for 26 years this young man's
coming and going what what I got to be
up at 5:30 again I just got home yeah
well Bravo congratulations
you